foreign
YouTube channel in this session we will
create a MP3 player using python but
before we begin if you love watching
Tech videos subscribe to our Channel
like the tutorial and hit the Bell icon
to now miss an update before we start I
hope the screen is clearly visible and
the audio is fine if yes please type in
yes if there are any issues to let us
know in the chat section and before
starting first we should have a look on
what we would create
so for that we will move to our code
simply run this
you can see that the take into window
has appeared and this is our media
player we have named it simply music
player we have the GIF that would be
running continuously
and we have the browse music button
which will direct you to the any folder
you want to open that have the MP3
player files
I have selected this folder it has four
files
and we'll play Hey there
you just click on that and click on the
play button
it will play the music
now just click on the post button
so this is our MP3 player
so before starting the coding
I have a simple question for you guys
so moving to that
so the question is who wrote the poem
Zen of python
a new Option so
then bonusly Tim Peters
Weirdo And rusam
or Kevin Goldsmith
you could see the poem here also you can
easily get this one you just have to
write import this you know interpreter
and just press enter you won't get the
poem
so please answer in the comment section
below and we'll update the correct
answer in the print comment
you can pause the video give it a
thought and answer in the comment
section
so moving to a code
first we will create a folder
and name it as
create
MP3 player
using python
and inside
you will open the command prompt
and write the command code space
sorry period and press enter
this will open up the editor that is
Visual Studio code
if you want you can use any editor you
have hands on any editor you can use
anyone
and here we will create a file and we'll
name it as player.py only
and we would require music also
for that and some gifs and some images
for our buttons you can easily
get those images from any
free images website or you can just get
them draw in the paint or photoshop them
you can
arrange them from anywhere
so we have our picks in this folder
so we'll copy all these and we have the
music folder
it has four files
and this is the copyright free music so
you can play on YouTube
we will
paste this enough folder only
that is create MP3 player using python
yeah
going back to our Visual Studio code
the first thing is we should install the
python packages before starting our
coding
so we would require the take into
package it is already installed as you
install the python if you want to
install it again just
go to a terminal
and write the command with install
TK
as you can see that the requirement is
already satisfied so you I don't have to
install it again
you can install it just writing the
command and press enter
and the next we have to install is the
pi game to import the mixer class
sorry the command would be
pip install Pi game
and press enter
you can see that the requirement is
already satisfied I have already
installed the pi game module you just
have to write the command and press
enter you will get them installed very
easily in the next module we need is
time
so you can install the date time module
or the time module
it's your wish
so we have
to write the command
web install date time
so it was not installed
on my system
it has been installed and
it doesn't have some
classes in the module it has installed
them and it says the requirement is
already satisfied for other modules okay
so now
and the last is OS module
let's turn the
this window is not going so we will just
go to the terminal
just get a terminal
and write the command here pip
install
OS
and press enter
so it will install the OS module for you
it is doing for me right now
and we would be using the take into
module to create the GUI and tick enter
is a python module that is used to
develop graphical user interface and as
I told you there's no need to install it
it is the part of the standard python
Library so it would be installed as you
installed python on your system
so it's downloading till then
you just import our packages
first will import
time and that we will use an
to get the GIF setup in our GUI
so we'll import the time and from tick
into
all the classes
and
we will import the field dialog
and from PI game we'll import the mixer
class to get a buttons functioning to
make our mp3 music video music
like MP3 file to start playing to pause
it and to resume it again
so for that I'll write the command
foreign
import mixer
it's still downloading
till then we'll import the OS also
it will get it
download it and installed for us
so first we'll create the tick enter
video window
for that we'll write the simple command
root
equal to
t k
and circular brackets and
hit the command root Dot
main Loop
and if we save it and run it
no sorry it was downloading
[Music]
um
just pause the downloading okay we'll
see it again so you can see that that
take enter window has appeared on the
screen it's the output
it's a simple take into video now we
will add functions to it we will add
size to it we will add background color
and we'll do other functionings to that
so tick enter provides many methods and
one of them is geometry method
and it is used to set the dimensions of
the take enter window as you have seen
so we will just position the main window
on the user's desktop we will use the
command root dot geometry for that
set the size as 485
cross
that is X only
and for y-axis it would be 700
and now
you would get it
290 points shifted from x-axis
and
10 points shifted from y-axis
and we have to put them in inverted
commas
we will save the file and run it again
you can see that the take into window
has changed its geometry and it has set
the x-axis as 485 and Y X is at 700 and
when it appeared it was
290
and see what dimension that uses it was
290 points apart from the x-axis and 70
sorry 10 points apart from y-axis yeah
290 and 10.
so now we'll give the title to this
window
for that we will write the command
through title
and just write that item
do you want to give it you can give it
anyway
so we will name it as simply music
player
and now we'll use the configure function
so take into configure function it is
used on any widget to change settings
that you may have applied earlier or
haven't applied yet
so for that we'll write the command
root dot configure
and we will set the background color
so
right
background
equal to an inverted commas we'll write
the hexa code
for this color
we are setting the gray color
for a background we'll save it
and run the file so you can see the
output
so we have set the simply music player
as the root title for taken top window
and we have configured the background
color right screen
so moving on
now we will use the resizable method it
is used to allow tick enter root window
to change its size according to the
user's need
as well as it will prohibit like it will
not allow you to change the size of the
window
the window you just saw on the screen
that was a take enter window so we will
use the resizable function and we will
prohibit will not allow anyone to change
its dimensions
so for that we'll write the command
root dot resizable
volts comma
for it so in this sizeable method user
can pass either positive integer or true
to make them into resizable to make
window non-new sizable user can just
pass zero or false we have passed faults
so our window won't be resizable
and save this file and run it again you
can see now we can't resize it
so first I will command this command and
save it and run it for you guys
you can see that
you can resize it now but after we write
this command
no one is allowed to resize The Tick
enter window
so we'll save this
and run it you can see
now no one is allowed to resize this
window
you won't get any option
so now
moving on as you have
seen the previous dimensions and the
demonstration of the simply music player
will create
as same as that only
so we will place the GIF here a label
here and place the buttons on that and
beneath that we will just create a label
and browse all the files there
foreign
so we'll start with the frame
for that we'll write the command
first we'll create a
variable and name it as lower frame and
a frame is a rectangular region on the
screen
it can be used as a foundation class to
implement complex widgets it is used to
organize a group of widgets so we'll be
creating a frame and we'll Place
different buttons on that that would be
the play button post button and the stop
button and the volume
that is just the image
we'll place the volume image there
so lower frame equal to
we will write frame to get a frame
and inside we will pass root
and get a background color as white
that will write the hexagon
hash and the hexa code for white color
is
FFF and that is six times you can go and
search on the web about the hexagotes
like which color is associated with
which hexa code or you can just write
the simple name of the colors you can
get your background set as well that
also
and here we'll set the width for our
frame
so width will set as 485 only it should
cover the whole window
in X dimensions
and for height we'll set it as 180.
we'll create the same simply multiplayer
as I have shown in you as I've shown the
demonstration earlier
so we have set the height as 180
so
now
we will use the Place method that allows
you to explicitly set the position and
size of a window or anything like we are
just creating a frame so it would use to
position and size of the frame
it would be either in absolute terms or
relative
to another window so for that
we will write the command
first
you will get the frame
that is stored in the lower underscore
frame
variable
and use the place function
to place it in a ticket window
and write the dimensions for that we
would start from x equal to 0
and paste it at y equal to
400.
now we'll save the file
and run it
okay we have 20 control already opened
so I closed it you could see that this
is the frame we have set it at x equal
to 0 and y equal to 400 so it would
measure
as y equal to 0 here and y equal to 400
here
so we have placed the frame now we will
place the buttons on that
and first we will set
a logo for simply music player
that we have
enough folder
so this is the logo for our simply music
player we will set it
pull that will write the command
first we will create a variable and name
it as image icon
and here we will use photo image
so
click after writing in this photo image
it would like it would create a photo
image object and you can use it
in other widgets that accept an image
argument that is some buttons they
accept image argument photo image
argument
you can use the images there also and
the image object is returned by the
photo image function
it's the easy to display a picture in
Python however the photo image class
only supports the GIF and PGM PPM
formats which is a concern jpeg jpg and
PNG are the formats that are most often
used
so now
in the photo image object we will just
write the location of the file
as we have it in the same folder so we
will write the name only that is logo
space PNG
and the extension that is PNG only
now
to get it set as icon photo we'll write
the command root dot icon photo
and
past argument as false comma
image underscore icon
now we'll save the file
first it will close the previous one
and run it
you could see that
the logo has been placed there
so
now moving on
we will create the menu
we will again run the file
so here we will create the menu to
browser music
for that first
we will create a variable menu
and create a photo image object
and
write the file name only as here we
don't have to set the part as all the
images are in the same folder only
so for this we will use the menu.png
that is the white inch I will show you
what you will get as output
so
we have to place this in inverted commas
and now for this we will create a label
so in Tinker in dig into some widgets
can display an image such as label and
button
is a widget that is used to implement
display boxes where you can place text
or images
so
we will create a label here
and paste the menu.png image on that
so to create it we'll write the command
we have started with label and inside we
will pass root
and the image
we will write the variable name here
that is menu
and now we will place it
will position it in our take into window
so for that write the command please
and inside
write x equal to 0
and
the dimensions
okay
so y would be
580
and would also set the width and height
for that
and width would be 485 so it could cover
the whole
sorry I didn't try to do it
would be 485 and now we will set the
height
I will set as 100 only guys
it would be
in the bottom section
so
you don't get much height so we'll save
this
and run the file
you can see that we have created a label
here also and a label here also and we
have pasted the white image place the
white image on that level
so this is the label that is of the
white color and now we have placed
another image on
another label
so I will show you what
purpose we have done that
so first we will create a button
that would be for the browse music
now it will write
first pass root and
then what text we want to show on that
button
that would be
house music
and then we will set the width of that
button
that would be 59
and then
would set its height
and
set the height as 1 only
and now you you can set
font also like which font you want
to get displayed on that button
for that
you just have to write want
equal to
and start the circular brackets
and inside you can write
which font you want I will go with
calibri
and font size would be 12.
and I want it bold
so in inverted commas I will write vault
and outside this circular bracket
I will set the foreground color
that is the text color only foreground
color
s black
you can write the hexa code we just
write the name of the color
and we will set the background color as
white for this button
use hexapod here
that is 60 Maps
and now
what function does this button do
so it will show us the music that
would be stored in our folder
we will browse the folder and it will
show us the mp3 mp3 files that would be
contained in that folder
so in command we would write the name of
the function that we will create to get
all the MP3 files
so we will
finance and we also calling
now outside this bracket
we'll place it
and showing error as we have note
to find the add music function so we'll
place it
at x equal to zero
y
equal to 550.
no
and scroll bar
so that when we get Ola MP3 files we can
just browse just by scrolling
so we can get all the MP3 files on that
small window we will create now
so we'll set the scroll bar for that
for that write the command
scroll bar
and inside
get off
play music
so first
will
set another frame
and we will
get it as
gray color only with that
we will write the command
frame underscore music
we will create a frame
and inside will pass root
and set the Border equal to 2
and
relief
equal to Rich
so we have set the relief equal to Rich
so relief is a style and it's a style of
a widget that refers to certain
simulated 3D effects and we are giving
the 3D fact to a button and that effect
is rich
so we will see that but before that we
have two
get a add music defined
showing a soup
no you won't get the taken to window as
we have to
Define the
and music
so we have created the frame and now we
will place this
and after that we will
create that music
function
for this we will write
name underscore music
that
moves the variable name and
period place
and now we will position it in a taken
term window
so we want it at x equal to zero
equal to
so we would place it at
585
and would so Define its width and height
so width would be 485
and height
is
100
yeah so we were creating the scroll bar
so first we'll create the scroll bar and
then Define the add music function
so now we will set the scroll bar in the
frame music
variable as you want the scroll bar in
that frame
I will show you in the demo only after I
create that music function
so first we'll create the add music
function only
so we will create it here
in the limit as add music
going to first you want that it should
have path and here we would use
file dialog
so it would pop out the dialog box
to the directory where which we would
assign or take it to
next
foreign
change
directory
pass the path here
Source equal to
are stored
list of directory
art
okay
we have problems here but now we will
resolve them
so first if the path we have chosen
and here we will change the path and in
this songs variable
we'll get the list of all the songs
in that directory
and now
we will
create
we'll run a for Loop
or song in songs
but all the songs we got
f
Ong ends with
MP3
that is dot MP3
let playlist
Dot
insert
group pass
and the process
and
pass the song
so we will
get this playlist variable working in
another function that would be the play
music function
so it should play the music for that
will
create the function
play
music
create a variable name
that would be music underscore name and
inside
playlist dot get
and make it active
and now
we will
print
music name
and this would be printed in the
terminal
first
active that is which music is playing
and now I'm going to use the mixer class
and music dot node
function and pass the playlist
the function node get and get it as
diff
and now
here we will
plate
now we are getting errors for playlist
so first
create the playlist variable that would
be
having all the songs in that
so but that will write
a variable playlist
and that would be equal to
it would have the list box
equal to
list box
and inside we'll pass the
name that we have created for music
and set its width
that would be equal to 100
and now we will set the font for that
so
you can see all the names of the MP3
files in the same font only
and for
that would write
Times New Roman
and set the font sizes
10.
and outside this bracket
will set the background color for the
playlist
called that right PG
and we will cite it as gray only
so
I have support for degree is
3333
and that is six times
we'll close the inverted commas
and set the foreground color
and the gray only
now
a select background
that would be of the light blue color
set the cursor
and send to I will explain you
what this means
first it will set the Border
equal to 0 only
Vice scroll command
that would be equal to
light blue
now we will set the
y scroll command
that would be equal to scroll dot set
so it should be used to scroll
so we have set the cursor equal to N2
that means that it would convert to hand
when we scroll on the list box
that is when we would try to select any
of the MP3 player files it would show us
the hand cursor
and
the background color is light blue we
have set and scroll command equal to
scroll load set
okay now we will configure it
okay
let me have some errors we will resolve
them and we will see the output also
just after this
so first we will configure the scroll
bar
so that will use variable only scroll
load config
and inside
we will
have the command
equal to playlist
Dot
to buy View
so we should have in the y-axis only
and now
go back to scroll bar
a shift and right
and fill the y axis
for that will write fill
equal to y
and now
we will
pack the playlist
playlist dot pack
replace it
side equal to right
and it should
build
both the sides
it should be filled
so that will write the command
which I cannot appear after keyword
arguments
okay we'll get it sorted
save the file
run it
so you can see that
we have the browse music button here and
if we click it we have the functioning
it will
select the folder
create MP3 player and this is the folder
that is music and we'll select it it has
four files
I'll show you in that also so this is
the folder it has four files
it is displaying us all the four files
and you can see that we have the cursor
as hand here that is we have set it as
hand to
so now
we will
do other functionings that is place the
JF run it and place the buttons so first
we will place the buttons
and run it
so for that
after this Frame music will start with
the buttons
so first we'll create the play button
for that we will create a variable and
name it as pattern play
and we will use a photo
a picture
put that button that will create a photo
image object
and pass the file for it
and we have that file name play1.png
so we'll just write the name of that
file in inverted commas
and now
we will
set the functioning
set the pattern will pass
root
and the image
is equal to
the variable we have set it for that
that is
button
play
skeptical play
and
will set the background color for the
button
that would be white only because we have
the white label here
so it would
be perfect for that and I will set the
Border
that would be equal to zero
and
okay we have to place it inverted commas
else it would be
functioning as a comment Only We have
set the border that is equal to zero now
height
okay
h a g h t
oh so just for both the spanning of
height
okay so I have to declare the height
first
so we will
get these buttons in 16 to 60 Dimensions
only we'll set the height as 60 and
width
also S60
and now we would set the command for
this button so what functioning should
it do
for that
we will write the function name
that is play music
and
now we will place this
at x equal to
215
and y equal to
487.
and we have created the play music
function above
you can see that it has the functioning
to play the music
we have used the mixer.music.lord
from the pi game
and it would get the playlist and the
active contents there and it would play
so we are done with a play button
we'll save it and run the file
I'm going to take into window is opened
first of all goes that
started
first we'll browse so this was the
folder getting music let's select this
folder you can see we have these four
files we'll click on the one
and just click on the play button
okay uh we forgot to add one functioning
so first
we will
create all these buttons and then add
all other functionings
now we will create the second button
that would be the stop button
put that
you will create a variable and name it
as button stop
and here also we'll create a photo image
object
dude
pass file and inverted commas
we have stop1.png for this
so I'll just write the file name
and in the next line we will Define the
functioning of this pattern
so inside button will pass root
and image
that is the variable
button stop
and set the background color
equal to White only
and that would be in the inverted commas
and now we'll set its border
that would be zero
and height and width would be 60 only
and after that we will set its command
that would be
mixer Dot
music
dot stop so we are using the mixer
cast the music class inside that and the
stop function
and now we'll place this
tick enter window with that we'll write
the dimensions for that x equal to 130
and y equal to 487
so we have created the stop button
we will save this and run the file
you can see that the stop button is
also displaying on a ticket window
and now
we will make our third button
that would be the post button
for that we'll use the pose one PNG this
is the image
so for that
you can just
copy these things
place it here
so button
pause equal to photo image and we will
use the image
pose one dot PNG
and
get it
we go yes we have set all others as big
so button pause background color white
water zero all right 60 with 60 command
would be mixer dot music dot pose
and we'll place it at
300 comma 487
we'll save this file
and run it
you can see that we have the pause
button
displayed here
now
we will get the volume button Note the
volume button just as image
so this is the image volume.png
we will
get it though
so for that we will create a variable
volume one
and create a photo
image object
and set the file location
and the location is
already placed in the same folder so
we'll just write the name of the file
that is volume.png
and that would be in the inverted commas
and now
we will place this
at
x equal to 20. and
y equal to 487
now we'll save this
and run the file
so we are having some errors
okay
we contactly use the place here
first
create another variable and create a
label for this image
so for that
we will use panel
and equal to
well
sign will pass root comma
that is equal to
volume one
and now
we will use the place
and place it at
x equal to
because and
300 and
why would peace
that would be 487.
so now we'll save this file and run it
you can see
okay
we have made a mistake here
so
it should be here so X would be less it
would be around 20 and Y would be same
for that only
so we'll change that
save this
and run the file again
yeah you can see that we have the volume
image
we have the play button the post button
and the stop button so we'll get the job
working for us
and now we will
get our GF working but before that we
will
make the mixer initialize so that uh
buttons they should function that is
play pose and stop
so we've imported the mixer class so we
will initialize it
I will save this
and run the file
now you can browse the music
click on the any MP3 file and
click on the play button
you can hear that the music is playing
so I will pause it
and now we will start with the
functioning of our gif
so we have to cut the previous part
and now
start with frame count
so the frame count of rgf is 30 and we
will store it in a variable
and now we'll create another variable
as frames and inside
start with
square brackets and create a photo image
object
and inside will pass the file
the GI file
the name of the file is A1 dot JF
and here we have to specify the format
of the file
put that you write format
equal to
in
commas
chair
and
index
and we'll set the index
and
I
assume we would be using the list
comprehension here
no we will run the loop
so for that right for
I
in
and use the range
of the frame count
so what we will do is
the GIF has so many images in that so we
have to run a loop so it would again
repeat itself
as the frame count would be equal to the
count
as the images would be repeated in a
loop we will set the count equal to 0
and repeat it again
so for that
now we'll create a function
and name it as update
inside will pass a variable Andy
create a variable with name frame and
inside
we will pass
IND variable
names
and as
this image would be displayed
we will increment
the IND variable
and if
I and D is equal to equal to frame count
that is if it has displayed all the
images in the gif
we will set it at zero and run it again
and would set the jfn label so
we will configure it
and we have to find the label also
so for that
label
equal to
label and so it will pass the root
and now we'll configure it
and pass image
equal to what
frame we have
currently click
and now
we will use the after function
and pass 40 milliseconds so that
the animation would start again
and pass the update function
the current IND
and now we will place the label
and x equal to 0 and y equal to zero
and again we will run the after function
and pass zero milliseconds and the
update function
zero frames
okay
let's find this
if statement only
okay
first we have to
place the label statement about no
now
we are done with a gif
save this
and then the file
so we are getting an error here
okay
so
subtitude
okay then save this file and run it
again
okay
encode displayed
so we have this label above
just browse the files select the folder
and click on any file and just click on
the play button you can see that our MP3
player is working
we'll just set the UI again
we'll close it
or you could stop it
so we will
get this
downwards
let's try to move the buttons
now we'll save the file
and click on run button
you can see that the GIF has taken the
whole frame
and now browse the files
and selected the folder and our if
statement will find the MP3 files and
click on the file
just click on the play buttons
[Music]
you can see that our simply music player
is working fine
so I will share the code link with you
in the description
and with that
we have come to the end of this session
I hope it was interesting and
informative if you liked it please let
us know in the comment section below and
also do subscribe to our Channel and
stay tuned for more from simpler
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here